we're going down memory lane okay we
obviously have to talk about your your
history as one of the ogs of reality
television yes isn't that crazy
oh no no wait a minute wait a minute
girl what are you putting on her face
who brought you here johnny they don't
get nothing on their face
nothing
will you turn around and tell the people
in front of jesus do you wear makeup on
set no
i'm on tick tock scrolling and clips of
your show constantly come up gnocchi is
too you guys must be on the same show
we're on the same
thing yes yeah so do you ever come
across clips do you ever go back and
watch because that was like home movies
do you know i've never
watched myself on tv
so any of these clips i've never seen
them even the ones yoki posts i've never
watched it i've never pushed play i see
the clip like i'll see her there talking
and you go no but i won't watch it why i
j i don't know i don't watch myself on
tv i've never watched my show
other than you've never seen kamora life
in the fab lane no
i've seen clips but i don't sit there
and watch even for editing purposes i
don't i don't i wouldn't be watching the
whole show through no does it make you
feel a certain type of way cringe
no one wants to hear their voice i don't
know those moments you might be used to
it but like i think mostly people are
like oh is that me i think for you that
show was so endearing it was so real i
feel like it was not it was not filtered
it was just a day in the life of an
executive it was and it was of a busy
working mom yes um and i i just think
that what what we showed and what we
were able to depict it was aspirational
it was showing you the way i mean yeah
our drama was like are you going to get
the fashion show done in time or are you
going to come in under the proper budget
right it wasn't like catty right you
know my kids were never like vulgar or
belligerent like you just didn't have to
do that sometimes tv is about let me
take my mind off and just mindlessly
watch something that's a train wreck
that makes me feel better about myself
people that's what we do that's our
culture there's a lot of shows like that
of course that's a lot of things we feed
on yes this wasn't that so it was um
important to me and impressive even to
be able to be top rated
even to this day i was um
not wholesome but like a little bit more
depicting of a family and yes and your
business and your business and being a
single mom or a married woman it doesn't
matter i had my ins and outs my ups and
downs it was a it was a good time and i
loved everything that we showed it was
how to build a business how to chase
your dreams how to produce shows
okay so you just said it was a good time
you know
it begs the question am i gonna do it
again would you do it again what would
it take to get you to share your life
with cameras again i didn't know i've
talked about it a lot
and then we always go to our talked
about it with with your team with people
with the team different producers call
me all the time people call me and try
to get me to be part of their show all
the time
all the time housewives all the time
all the time
but here's what i just don't understand
i said don't watch tv are they mean to
each other are they rude to each other
cause the clips i've seen or the things
i've heard they're kind of fighting do
not bring up my children or my husband
period end of story okay and if you do i
will comfort you till the end of days
okay if you come from my husband and
kids i will [ __ ] hunt you down
is everyone clear yeah we're clear is
that a threat or a promise
it is a fact
i like kyle you know i like kathy i like
garcelle like i like these women these
are the housewives you're bi-coastal you
could also join new york but are they
gonna like invite you to a dinner party
and then
edit it to look a certain way and then
make someone pick up the china and go oh
that's what she cause honey i'm not the
one okay so
i don't have the patience for that
you're not interested it sounds like
you're not interested in having uh like
a social dynamic captured on tv not a
fake
produced for
ratings drama i don't want to create a
fake drama i want to compel people teach
people aspire people uplift them i want
to show them how to be bad bees how to
look great feel great manage everything
and fall apart if you can if you have to
but get back up and keep going that's
what i want to show on tv with the real
housewives where do you stand last time
you spoke with et you said that there
there were rumblings they definitely
have asked me
every couple years in between seasons or
in between people they definitely have
asked me but i've never been in like
real talks i was like through someone
else or through an agent or through
whatever still rumblings they call me
every season someone's asking me all the
time someone tells me would you do it
like you just asked me now so i'm not i
just
it for you it sounds like it's a no i
don't know i would take a meeting maybe
i should take a meeting why they call
you but you don't take the meeting i
actually recently just said that i would
but then i don't know what happened to
that meeting it didn't happen so i'll
maybe i will take a meeting i'll see
because i do love all those women okay
but you know no one's going to promise
you they're not going to be like
produced catty we'll see okay so
tbd is the status pbd is the stuff on
real housewives you just said you want
to uplift people you want to make people
feel good i wouldn't mind doing it yeah
i'm bicoastal i'm now i'm a boy mom i
have three young young boys i don't mind
i don't i wouldn't mind but it would
just have to be under the right
circumstances i've talked talk talk to
so many people to networks to production
companies so i think we're just seeing
are you friends with kris jenner yes i
feel like you should have a chat with
her should i she's at the top of the
total maybe i will that and you know
what that is a great idea actually and i
i never thought about it she's the
executive producer chris we may need to
talk
and i love you but we may need to talk
about this so it happened right now and
it was your idea i mean i should ask i'm
really going to think about i'm not
going to like call her tomorrow and be
like let's talk tv but i'm going to
think about it you're right i want to
also take even more of an of a deep dive
you were a judge on season one of
america's next top model yes quite
honestly 26 is a little late to be
busting into the top model game i get a
lot of clips of that also on tick tock
it's just the show is now being
evaluated all the time right it's it's
just being evaluated through a much
different 2022 lens so it's probably was
a hot mess it's been it's been compared
to it's being picked apart for you know
some people call it problematic and the
way that we spoke to women back in the
day
do you have an opinion on that well i
feel like when i started with the show
and it was the first show and i was um
very good friends with tyra she was in
my wedding she's my kid's godmother um
it was a little bit different maybe than
how it ended up so many seasons later
and i do believe it had like a
tremendously successful run it did and
she did and i think probably as time
goes on it takes on a life of
its own so to speak that
ratings and numbers and
dollar thing i think that sometimes can
get in the way i don't know but it
didn't start out that way it started off
really as something that was
aspirational and that women wanted to do
and i mean women were young women and
young girls were breaking their necks to
be a part of this or to be picked or
come to these cattle calls well i see
now when i hear things that are said
about it i'm like okay i can see how you
would say that like most of the things
that were said i think i and again i
don't know we're watching we're on the
same algorithm but i'm like yeah that's
true
yeah that happened someone did that yeah
okay maybe not in season one because
you're just getting started right but i
think there's a lot of fact and again i
didn't hear everything and see
everything i think we owe it to
ourselves and to these young women and
to you know
as a community we owe a bit more a bit
more responsibility a bit more you know
but a lot of those problems are
have been and are still now prevalent
i mean it
far exceeds
america's next top model right it goes
into every agency every young girl which
is why i maybe don't want my kids to
model
[Music]
you